In the previous chapter we finalized our initial opening shot by creating our camera and the
character animations.
Now I'm going to go ahead and just close our sequence and go to our content browser
and in the sequence 90500 we're going to go to the SEQ, I'm going to double click
and open our sequence example final.
The reason why I wanted to do this is to show you the final shot that we're creating
and what you can do next on your own time for establishing the remaining two shots.
So I'm going to select my camera cuts and go ahead and just view through this and if
I play it you'll see here's our opening shot and then you'll notice that it will
shift to our second shot and then lastly the third shot.
So these are completely up to you and your artistic interpretation what you want
to build for your shot but the principles are generally the same.
So we're going to have our camera, we'll have our character, we'll have our animations
for that character and the keyframes that are associated with that.
Now on the final one there's a few other steps that we've gone through to create
additional lighting, to create additional movement, all of those things are completely
up to you on how you want to build them, again to build the shot that you're looking
for.
But just take note again we're not going to cover it in this course building the two
additional shots.
These are up to you to go in and create however you feel.